a sus 60 años rodrigo chávez economista
y ex funcionario del banco mundiales se
quedó con la presidencia de costa rica
en segunda vuelta con 54% de apoyo se
venció a josé maría figueres ex
presidente en los años 90 y prometió
cambios rápidos para el país
centroamericano que en los últimos años
ha visto empeorar su situación económica
alrededor del 23% de la población es de
5,1 millones se vive en pobreza y una
creciente disparidad de ingresos lo
convierte en uno de los son más
desiguales del mundo el desempleo está
en casi el 15 por ciento vamos al
análisis del nuevo período presidencial
en costa rica y para ello nos acompaña a
gaspar de estrada él es politólogo de la
universidad saint spot de parís gaspar
gracias a usted chávez dice que va a
usar la herramienta del referendo para
gobernar es esto factible y con sólo 10
escaños en el parlamento como será su
gobernabilidad
hola buenos días me parece efectivamente
que ese es el punto central
de digamos las preguntas que muchos
analistas se hacen en el día de hoy con
un escenario que no es nuevo es decir en
costa rica ya
desde hace varias elecciones el congreso
está cada vez más fragmentado en esta
elección pues no es la excepción el
partido de chávez va a tener 10 escaños
sobre 57 no tener esa perspectiva
chávez propone este ideal de referéndum
sin embargo a mí me parece que en lugar
de poder materializar esto en la
práctica yo creo que más bien lo que él
debería de hacer es intentar montar una
coalición que le permita tener una
mayoría política en el congreso si no
tiene esta mayoría política en el
congreso me parece que será difícil para
el poder llevar a cabo pues estas
tentativas de referéndum porque está
claro que él es reaccionario mire porque
al final no tuvo peso el antecedente de
acosos sexuales del nuevo presidente de
costa rica y bueno francamente tampoco
tuvo peso en la campaña ni siquiera el
caso de figueres y la denuncia de
corrupción eso no le impidió llegar a
segunda vuelta
así es infelizmente
estos temas no tienen un impacto no
tienen el impacto electoral que deberían
de tener me parece que son pues
acusaciones pues bastante
severas y
efectivamente podemos lamentar que esto
no no tengo un impacto mayor sin embargo
yo creo que ahora pues el presidente
electo va a tener que mandar señales
muy claras de decir que este tipo de
actos no son tolerables ya sea en su
gobierno y sobre todo en la sociedad
costarricense
le quiero preguntar si el presidente en
su opinión está en capacidad de poner en
marcha un plan contra la deuda del país
y revertir este retroceso económico
costa rica- accedió el año pasado a
1.780 millones en asistencia del fondo
monetario internacional y el gobierno
dijo que va a impulsar una serie de
cambios fiscales y de medidas de
austeridad que hará
bueno yo creo que esa es la principal
pregunta durante el gobierno del
presidente alvarado como un intento de
hacer una reforma fiscal esta reforma
fiscal no pudo llevarse a cabo
justamente porque los problemas en el
congreso no obtuvo la mayoría para poder
llevar a cabo este está esta propuesta
la pregunta que nos hacemos hoy es con
esta minoría política con apenas 10
escaños sobre el 57 como al gobierno
podrá justamente llevar a cabo la
reforma fiscal que costa rica necesita
para poder aumentar sus ingresos y por
ende también tener mayores recursos para
generar mayores políticas sociales en un
contexto en el cual pues se costa rica
como otros países de américa latina
sufrió mucho por la pandemia otro de los
hechos que llama la atención es ya
mirando un poco hacia atrás es porque
esta elección se dio en una forma tan
cerrada que decir de la abstención de 60
por ciento en primera vuelta además del
42 por ciento en segunda vuelta que es
lo que nos indican estos fenómenos de
cara al nuevo mandato que comienza en un
mes
bueno yo creo que hay un hartazgo un
atasco en la sociedad de costarricense
de hecho en ese sentido no es
sorprendente que un candidato pues
outsider que también viene por un
partido que apenas fue creado hace tres
años y logró llegar a la presidencia de
la república después de un paso efímero
por el ministerio de hacienda durante el
gobierno de carlos alvarado un paso de
seis meses y esta extensión pues también
traduce pues también no sólo una
decepción frente a la oferta política
pero también inclusive con guilherme con
perdón de chávez en el sentido que pues
también estas denuncias de abuso sexual
este pues también tuvieron un impacto en
un 7 fran g electorado yo creo que lo
más importante para el día de mañana es
cómo hacer para que la clase política
vuelva en costa rica pero de manera más
general en amena en américa
vuelva a conectar con las sociedades
porque no podemos olvidar que inclusive
antes de la pandemia en 2019 ya había
muchas manifestaciones mucho descontento
en la región y bueno eso también incluye
a costa rica sigamos hablando de la
región el presidente tendrá que tener
mucha claridad precisamente en su
política exterior el medio bloomberg es
de cita que el mercado centroamericano
es el segundo más importante en términos
de exportación y de alianzas comerciales
que son los que le permiten a un país
como costa rica crecer cuál es el
impacto entonces de la política exterior
costarricense en la región
latinoamericana
bueno es importante yo creo que hay
varios hay varios maneras de ver las
cosas la primera es el tema ambiental es
un tema en el cual en costa rica y en
particular durante el gobierno del
actual presidente carlos alvarado ha
tenido un cierto tipo de liderazgo en la
agenda ambiental sobre todo por la
manera como costa rica produce su
electricidad y su energía que es una
manera muy limpia comparado a otros
países
y creo que desde ese punto de vista en
costa rica sólo tiene a ganar si
continúa en esa trayectoria apostando a
las energías renovables ya esta
transición energética por otro lado yo
creo que hay otro tema fundamental
del
del torno de costa rica que es como el
futuro de américa central una región
después sufrió mucho por la pandemia que
históricamente tiene muchos problemas ya
sea de corrupción pero también a nivel
fiscal con estados que recaudan poco que
pueden por ende pueden hacer pocas
políticas públicas y con un movimiento
migratorio cada vez mayor hacia eeuu
entonces desde esa perspectiva qué es lo
que pueden hacer los países de la región
poblado pero por otro lado otros países
ya sea eeuu teniendo en cuenta que hay
una rivalidad creciente con china para
tener realmente una relación con este
país asiático yo creo que unos temas a
seguir en costa rica como en otros
países de américa central será a ver
cómo se expresa esta rivalidad entre
eeuu y china y también qué es lo que por
ejemplo europa podría aportar
y en ese sentido y creo que lo que haga
el próximo gobierno costarricense pues
tendrá que observarse con mucho cuidado
y que no alcanzamos a conversarlo pero
será un punto tener en cuenta y es la
demanda cada vez mayor de la ciudadanía
latinoamericana por políticas con
enfoque en derechos humanos gracias a
gaspar estrada politólogo de la
universidad de saint de parís